yo yo yo yo yo welcome back to the edge
with your boy Michael Parsons live in
the bleacher report app ah as always
drop any questions and comments that you
have for me I'll respond during the show
during and a little bit after um but y
know it's a great week when you always
got to win Victory Monday and let's get
straight into it cowboys
Panthers way to win uh way to get a win
on the road I know it's been rough for
us on the road um we had two crucial
wins but we also had two crucial losses
well three with the Arizona
49ers and obviously the Eagles but to
get a big one on the road that's huge um
they said I had added motivation uh
quiet people for my standards for last
week I and I would say yeah like I
obviously I was not happy about how I
played and things like that and just
other factors but you know for me it was
just about being locked in and focused
and not having that come again and then
just you know there's always some
naysayers when they always want to you
know they always want to raise up more
of your failures and what you're not
doing than what you're actually doing
and um competing so uh you it's always
good to put you know some hush to the
music you feel me um obviously tied my
career high two and a half sacks jron K
stole my half a sack um we still arguing
to this day to this moment we've been
arguing all yesterday all the day on who
should get the full sack obviously none
of us is going to get that full sack now
so it is what it is um but you know
there was actually a funny story about
the game yesterday and it was really
just about me and the C4 and I know
everybody's been hearing about it and
this is what really happened and I don't
think people understand so um mares bell
comes up to me was like Hey man take
this C4 this will how you go for like
three sacks right um and I was like man
I I'm good bro like I don't need that
stuff so then you know it's like man
just take it straight to the the head
here go scoop of powder so he Scoops a
scoop of C4 and he's you know he you
know cuts it off at the top so it's just
a you know a regular leveled off scoop
of C4 and I'm like man like and I seen
other people take it they like so I'm
like you know what like if everybody
doing it and listen people and this is
why I say don't fall for peer pressure
right because this is like mad true of
like regular peer pressure if it's
alcohol if it's any other narcotic
whatever and it's not something that you
do please do not do it right um but
basically he you know scooped that
powder right and uh I was like man I see
everybody doing it and I do want to go
off today so let me just take this C4
right so I took it and I Tred to swallow
it no water no nothing like just regular
C4 powder and I was like oh oh man like
sheesh and I drunk my water I was like
man that that D was strong but I
instantly I felt like zipped up like ooo
like
cool anyway um you know and I took it
like already after I warmed up so I
didn't like do no uh no like warm up
with that C4 like nothing right and uh
so I hit the field right and you know I
still don't feel it I'm telling you
by um within the first three plays my
heart was
like I'm like yo who I'm like and like I
like I'm I'm push it through cuz I'm
like maybe I got to get my second win
right I'm like man I got to get my
second win that's all it is like cuz you
know how it is like when you especially
like when you coming a week like maybe I
just didn't run enough like but I was
like nah my condition is not this bad
like there's just no way like I'm I'm
like so I'm get to the side line I'm
like coach I can't breathe dog like I
like this is crazy like My Heart's On
Fire he's like are you a good to go I
said no like give me some help bro they
like they like what I'm like Jim what do
I do I'm going to the train I'm like bro
like it felt like like I don't know if
people ever felt like it's like when you
get I don't know I don't really
understand but when you get to some
point where you never been like I just
didn't know how to react they like man
eat food drink a lot of water drink a
lot of water so I was like man I was I
was just drowning stuff and bro when I
tell you like my man he's like just
breathe bro go get the oxygen
like but anyway I was like bro I just
got throw up like that's the only way so
I went to the side and I felt my
diaphragm just keep EXP Bing and I just
pull that trigger right before I pull
that
trigger and that's why I was like I'm
cool off the the C4 life but honestly I
might have to get another like half
scoop or maybe like a small little bit
of C4 because that thing did have me
like wired as heck but whatever bro like
just be careful when you trying new
stuff like when you try new stuff just
be mad careful be mad careful cuz like I
was scared for my life for a little bit
obviously I'm okay uh nothing's wrong
but hey when you taking some stuff you
ain't never take before just be very
very careful um but anyway uh that
that's kind of like my story of you know
listening to my teammates because they
wanted to see my success um and I never
do that again um Point Bank period like
that that that's over for me um but my
typical pregame routine is like I'm just
warming up like I don't really take no
supplements like I don't do nothing like
uh like I'm not really a like supplement
powder anything like I'm just wired from
the get-go like that's just how my mind
is like that's just kniv and me so for
me to go down and try to do that I
really came outside my my body frame and
just goes to show you like I just got to
keep being me I just got to keep being
me because he almost put me out bro um
he put me out bro I'm coughing choking
like all this stuff like I was I was
going insane so just be very very
careful about trying new things but
other hands I want to give a big shout
out to my man Don Bland tied the NFL
record for the most picked sciss in the
season I truly believe he will break the
record this year I truly believe and I
mean what he's doing right now is
special and and you know there's been
and my guy Trey said he should be a
defensive player the year conversation I
said that yesterday and without a doubt
he should be in defensive play of the
Year conversation I mean
100% uh and and this is where I get kind
of mad at the League because it makes it
so hard like we don't really give the
awards to the best players we just get
it for the best category so like
defensive player year is always gonna go
to a rusher um most times unless someone
has an insane year um like MVP is always
gonna go to a quarterback uh the
offensive player years is always gonna
go to either uh a receiver or running
back but it never goes out to usually
the best player um so so that's kind of
like where I get mad if he doesn't come
in conversation it is quite annoying he
should be the odds should be in his
favor I mean we haven't seen something
he's doing um since 72 maybe it was like
a crazy stat he's one of four people
ever to have four uh uh interception
returns for touchdowns like he he's
playing at a same level he's not giving
up a lot of yards um I mean we're just
we're just blown away by the production
he's putting up bro I mean he he's
unbelievable and he needs to be in a
conversation at the end of the day I
mean honestly he needs to be in that mvp
conversation like I think this is beyond
defensive play of the year he should be
in a lot of conversations he should be
waking people up um and and that's Point
Blank period and and and if you say oh
you know he has to do it for and and I
understand right uh he doesn't have the
name he doesn't have uh things like that
but he's building that he's waking
everybody up he should be in that
conversation uh you know this is in a
celebrity cont cont he's playing great
football right now um he should be all
pro po bowler locked and he should be
conversation for defense player of the
year and MVP without a doubt um let's
not just keep giving these Awards way um
to rushers and quarterbacks and things
like that let's let's expand on this and
start giving it to the players that
actually deserve these MVPs uh Tyreek
Hill I I seen a crazy stat on him too
this week he's the first receiver ever
to have over 1,200 yards within like the
first 10 11 games like that's absurd bro
like that's AB like he should be MVP but
yet Tua is up for MVP Tua wasn't doing
this without Tyreek Hill and yes they're
Tandem and yes they're they're great
together but Tyreek Hill is still making
the what he's doing after the catch is
quite just unbelievable like like are we
serious like I seen a picture of five
people around this man he outran
everybody like two is not doing that
work those his yards that Tyreek Hill's
getting yes he's getting the ball to his
hands but at this point I believe I can
get the ball to Tyreek Hill let me be
your quarterback tyreq you making this
job Look So Easy like you're so good bro
like no doubt about it you should be in
this MVP conversation we need to change
how we look upon these things because uh
what receivers are doing after the catch
and things like that is just truly
amazing so that's one thing we got to do
is switch up the conversations give give
get let's give it to the best players
who truly deserve it um what was my
assessment of Bryce young uh after
playing against him I still think Bryce
has great potential I think he's a good
player uh like I said before he just
doesn't have a lot around him um the
lineman his old line could be a littleit
better uh his receivers uh besides Adam
th who is consistently making big play
after big play for him in crucial
moments uh I don't see a lot there you
know uh or at least their system is not
building enhance um to build there they
have a great run game a great
quarterback they just got to keep
building their system and keep getting
better and better and I think Bryce
young will he can turn that organization
around but it's hard to put uh I don't
know how Bryce JIS but a rookie
quarterback to flip a whole oranization
in one year is just we just never seen
that be done before um I mean burrow was
flashing Deshawn Watson is flashing CJ
strad is flashing um but at the end of
the day they they're still taking losses
because they're still catching up right
so I still think he has a good chance I
think CJ strride is gonna make playoffs
um but he he also has help their defense
is playing at a super high level DeMarco
Ryan offensive coordinator They're all
playing at a super high level and
coaching at a super high level and it
just makes everything work better Bry
str's 22 and the odds of us expecting
him to turn down a franchise who's been
having top 10 pick after top 10 pick
after top 10 pick around in one year the
odds are just not likely you know um so
let's give Bryce young time I think he
will be a good quarterback in this
league he just needs time and he's way
faster than what people think I'm
telling you right now um he is way
faster what people think there was a
point where he took off on me and I was
like and I would say I'm pretty fast and
y'all would agree with me I'm pretty
fast and he took off on me and I was
very shocked he's way faster on people
think he moves better in the pocket what
people think uh he's an extremely good
player let's get into the NFL what y'all
come here to be enough about the Cowboys
because we're always going to talk about
the Cowboys but let's get into the bills
uh the Bills lost to the Broncos 24-22
on Monday night um Josh Allen to 15 for
26 177 yards one touchdown two
interception and there were some
controversy on Twitter uh from my dog my
brother uh Trayvon he said man 14 kind
of get up out of there followed by let's
not forget he didn't start going off to
uh bro got there what are my thoughts um
I wish Trey was on the show so he could
kind of do this for him and I I'm never
uh bashing uh Trey because that
obviously that's my brother you know I
always say you know I tell him if he's
in a wrong but in his statements
absolutely uh I don't know if Stefan
dicks gotta leave Josh Allen I think
think Josh Allen is making mistakes and
that that tends to happen uh you know he
does make mistakes sometimes but he is a
good quarterback um and you know Josh
Allen did start separating himself when
Stefan digs got there so is he wrong no
but sometimes you know our emotions get
the best of us his emotions uh tend to
May him do that I would say because you
know um you don't want to bring
controversy uh to another team and
obviously when you have when you're
family right Stefan and Trey's family uh
it brings controversy in tormo in the
locker room I know Steph and Josh
probably squashed at like listen uh we
got to focus on our season but it kind
of brings in outside noise and uh
negativity and things like that so is
Trey wrong no he's not but is he wrong
to put on Twitter and uh storm it you
can say that you know if if you're
looking from the negative aspect you
know um so that's kind of my thoughts I
I just think the timing of it was wrong
because when they're clicking is good
right everything's always good when it's
clicking when it's working when you know
Steph has 1,400 yards on the year when
he has touchdown passes everything um
it's a special duel and we all know that
Steph and Josh has a special uh
relationship on the field and no one can
break that up uh but when it's not
clicking we just can't always uh flip
the page and say it's not working and
the trade you know that's kind of always
the uh easy way out you know you got to
live through the good and the bad uh and
and that's just the reality of it
um we can't always just and I think
that's kind of been going on a
generation like oh we hate something we
don't like it all right let's just give
up let's move on let's go to another
situation but in reality what we all
know the grass ain't always green on the
other side so always remember that
people don't give up uh I know things
get ugly and you may not be in a
situation where you want to be but grass
ain't always greener um and you just got
to always keep praying and wishing for
the best for them outcomes and turn it
around because that builds character
that builds adversity that builds
everything overcoming it builds
commitment it builds discipline so many
factors in your life uh that I I hope
people don't keep passing up
on um bills followed up with a big win
over the Jets um they followed their OC
kend dorsy the bills are six and five
with a big stretch coming up will they
make the playoffs I do believe the bills
are talented enough to make the playoffs
they are good I think Josh Allen
realized his mistakes and I think he's
turning around with the game he played
against the Jets he's limiting where he
wants to put he's not uh forcing things
I think when you have crazy abilities
crazy arm Talent
um uh you got like you have you have all
these tangibles and you kind of so used
to making highlight plays right and I
think Mahomes had to adjust to this
right when he had Tyreek Hill he was
kind of making crucial mistakes and it
got to the point last year where he was
like all right I don't have Tyreek hill
now so now I have to play smart football
right so when you have to play smart
football and and this is what I think
Josh Allen is learning when you have to
play smart football uh you kind of just
got to take what the defense gives you
uh people are adjusting to Josh and
doing things like that and I think he
has to take he has to do more smart
football taking what the defense gives
him getting off the field Don't Force
the turnovers don't force it downfield
and just make them actually beat you
make their offense beat your defense you
have a great defense you have a great
offense uh don't kill yourself uh that's
the nature of the game it's a game of
inches do not kill yourself so I think
think if Josh Allen continues to play at
a good level and he has a tough schedule
coming up he even plays us um he can
push this team to make playoffs um
especially because we saw what's going
on with uh DeShaun Watson um and we see
what's going on with the bills so
there's going to be a way for them to
get in they just have to keep winning
and playing smart
football uh and speaking of Deshawn
Watson and Joe burrow I mean these QB
injuries are ridiculous they announced
Joe burrow is out for the remaining of
the season with a Tor ligament Deshawn
Watson has soon season ending shoulder
uh shoulder uh surgery uh and here's a
list of the QBs out for this season um
what do these injuries say about the
current what do these injuries say about
the current state of League all right
let's look at it Daniel Jones Kurt
cousin Deshawn Watson Joe burrow Anthony
Richardson Aaron Rogers it's saying that
like we as much as you try to and and
QBs are the most protected players in
the NFL you can't prevent some of these
things uh some of these things is just
nature of the game right and that's just
reality of it uh the injuries suck right
we would love to see what the just look
like with Aaron Rogers we would love to
see what a healthy bur looks like and we
kind of saw it for a little bit uh when
he came back from his CF injury we
started seeing uh Deshawn Watson turning
things around and Cleveland um he was
winning so it it sucks but you know the
beautiful about it you start to see
adversity you see these teams turn
around and they have to work with what
you have right uh I think Josh jobs is
doing a great job of working where he
has stepping into these roles um and you
kind of get that super uh superhero and
villain look about the NFL right can a
guy come in and step up and I think
we're gonna see that with the Jets uh
especially with the Zack Wilson
situation Um Zack Wilson has now been
moved to third string quarterback and
it's tough right everyone knows on the
show that I'm rooting for Zack Wilson I
wanted Zack Wilson suceed and things
like that I think the biggest thing for
Zack Wilson if he wants to continue to
be in this league
um he's going to have to learn and I
don't know what's going on in their
building and I I'm just saying from my
point of view and what I'm seeing um
he's got to learn how to make others
around him better and find a way to get
the ball and uh and and it sucks for QB
you take a lot of blame right I don't
think Zack's terrible um as as much as
everyone else does um I just don't think
he plays with the same passion and
emotion of of other people you know I
like when I watch Patrick Mahomes play I
see the excitement I see effort like I
see I see I just see the energy like he
he wants it like you see the guts you
see even out of C CJ stra a young player
that has ball he's like get the ball
back to me I'mma go down there and I'm a
score right you see that out these
players I just don't see that as Zack he
doesn't have the same confidence and it
sucks because so many people stripped
his confidence right and he had the only
people that believed in him and and
that's coach Salah who said I'm not
moving on from Zack he's playing well
he's doing the Small Things um when
those people go away from you that's
kind of sad it's sad to be honest with
you and and you kind of hate that and I
don't know what Zack did besides based
off what he's doing on Sunday um to get
these people to go away from him um
maybe he's not living in the system his
confidence he don't trust himself I I
don't know what it is but Zach if you
want to continue to be in this league
you have to turn a page you have to find
a way to believe in yourself you have to
find a way to turn yourself around
because there's people that believed in
you you want to went second pick for
nothing there's people that believed in
you there's people that building that
believes in you you got to believe in
yourself you got to turn a way to become
a winner the best way to be you be the
best third string possible and you find
a way to uh still find a way to be on
that team because right now it's not
positive and I know what that that mind
is like right um I know what it's like
to not have no one believe in you but
you actually had people that believed in
you had at your back and you just didn't
take advantage of it so now you got to
find a way to stand this league and now
that's the really hard part and how to
get those people to believe in you again
and that's really harder so I I just
wish my best wishes for Zack Wilson um
because it's a tough uh you know it's a
tough spot to be in um especially
because Rogers said he was aiming to
come back in late December um now at
this point with a foreign six record
should Aaron Rogers come back probably
not uh the odds of them um I I would
love to see what Tim Bo do and I might
come back to this next week uh to see
how it affects and what the difference
is him in the lineup um but if they
don't win games here soon they might as
well save Rogers and they said they were
pursuing Devonte Adams and wait for that
tandem to get back together um if
Devonte if they even let Devonte Adams
go so I think with Devonte Adams and
Garrett Wilson and a bunch of the others
this might be I mean they already got a
superstar team but this might put it
over the top I mean this would just be
outright ridiculous um and it probably
wouldn't be fair for the rest of the
league uh just having uh a number one I
think Garrett Wilson's a number like I
mean it's almost like AJ Brown and
Devonte Smith at this point but uh
obviously a little bit better with
Devonte Adams because I I still believe
he's a one of the top receivers in this
game and he's I mean the stuff he does
is just insane but a guy just talked
about CJ stra everyone was talking about
his pregame routine uh what is the
advantage of warming up to every sport
right I think every sport has uh it
blessings in the curse right baseball
warming up the shoulders basketball I
don't know what the basketball is CJ's
out there looking like he actually got a
stroke game like he could shoot uh he
still has yet to beat me in basketball
and I'm G just put that out there like
that uh but I think it has it has a
great thing like I was in the offseason
I always do wrestling we did boxing and
things like that it just works and
infiltrates other muscles that you won't
working on game day things like that
wrestling your hands uh you know hips uh
leverage things like that that you want
to keep intact uh keep into your game if
I say CJ could go pro at another sport
he would probably say basketball when I
would say basketball too CJ's a
competitor uh he's always going one of
the big moments he doesn't shy from him
you see it early on in his rookie career
I mean I mean I think that could truly
be special uh CJ probably go pro at
basketball and the Texans got the win
over Arizona CJ did throw three in a
ceptions I'm not faced by it I mean it
happens to the best and he still won uh
but this was his
response Steph don't stop shooting I'mma
let keep letting it ride and that's 100
per. that's the type of confidence that
you want Zack Wilson to have CJ has Tom
Brady conf confidence Patrick Mahomes
confidence I was watching uh the the QB
show and Patrick Mahomes like man they
playing down I'm about to let it rip at
at the end day you got to you got people
to keep respecting it I mean don't I
mean he just threw for 400 500 I mean
multiple 300 games to kid special uh he
should never doubt confidence uh a
couple bad reads doesn't face him he's
still a legit he's still in an MVP
conversation he's turned around this
organization uh and that's the type of
you should love that confidence uh in in
your quarterback without a doubt I mean
he's a special player and he's gifted
the bronos have won four straight games
their next two games are Browns and
Texans is Russell Wilson back absolutely
I think I'm glad to see Russ proving
people wrong I mean he's dying he's been
efficient this year he's been doing
everything and that goes to show you how
good of a coach Shawn Payton is right uh
this is a completely different Russell
Wilson he's managing the clock I mean
Russell Wilson is playing extremely good
football and I don't want people to
confuse that he is winning games he's
proving people wrong and a lot of people
said earlier in the year that they
should get rid of him they should trade
him away let him go and just you know
try to get probably Caleb Williams Drake
Ma or whatever these young guys in the
draft and I'm so glad that I'm seeing
his success cuz he's a God loving and
fearing man and I'm loving to see what
he's doing right now and I think think
the Broncos can make a push the uh I
think the AFC side is very lopsided
right now especially with a lot of
injuries coming from that side and I
definitely think there's that creates a
lot of opportunities for them um so we
love to see that uh and and that brings
up to another guy Caleb Williams a guy
um that we've been talking about Caleb
William lost his third straight game
over the weekend uh was that his final
game of his career uh it could be um and
that and that sucks he's not playing in
the New York's game um you know I don't
think you and The Season's about over um
once he finishes his year I mean there's
no big game opportunity for him I don't
think uh his his draft stock can go any
higher I don't really think he could go
lower um and at this space he should do
his best for him in his career you know
uh they're probably going to some
uh technical techno bowl or something
like that hey Caleb just go get your
money go be great whatever finish the
year out strong with your team and uh
you know go do his best for you and your
family at this point um and and I feel
bad for him I seen them cry that
competitor in him I think he's gonna be
a I think he's gonna be a really good
NFL quarterback um and he should go do
his best for him here's the current
draft order let's look at the odds
honestly I think there's a big
opportunity for the Patriots to trade up
and get him him um or maybe even the
Giants I think the Giants um or the
Patriots have a great opportunity to go
trade up and get him because I do not
think uh the Chicago Bears would take a
quarterback especially how good uh
Justin Fields was playing and now I mean
honestly that was a crazy can we talk
about that Lions game Lions versus
Chicago for a second they were up 12
points with three minutes left if that
doesn't tell you a lot about the Lions
um and who they can be in this uh
playoffs and who we have to face that is
a team that doesn't fear anything they
were down 12 uh aidah Hutson ended the
game the lions are playing at extremely
high level I I seen Eminem talking about
them that's a team people should be
scared of uh that's a team that didn't
give up and I mean that was a special
and gutsy win I mean goly uh that was
that was PR CR but Justin Fields played
really good that game and I think think
Justin Fields will continue to keep
getting better and better I do think the
Chicago Bears will get Marvin Harrison
for Justin Fields uh Marvin Harrison and
DJ Moore will be a special tandem um and
and that's something to see but the
great news is guys guess what
Thanksgiving is coming up oh oh if this
is one of my favorite
holidays and it just gives us a moment
and and I just want to give you a moment
to be thankful for oh I'm so thankful
for my family I'm thankful for uh the
Dallas Cowboys I'm thankful for all of
Cowboys Nation uh I'm thankful for my oh
my sweet little baby girl oh me me
that's my heart and soul right there um
people I I just always say take a moment
and you know get out sometimes get
outside the present of your life and
just give a moment what you're thankful
for uh you should always say what you're
thankful for every day but this is a
thankful opportunity you have your
family and friends around and obviously
you have the most delicious meal of the
people what you're thankful for and you
break bread if I had to get my top five
favorite sides right my top five
favorite sides and I'm all about the
combination the combination like I know
some people don't like their food
touching right I love when my food touch
so like all my foods have to be colled
together tipe so I'm GNA put it like
this right so five will probably be my
stuffing and it has to have the gravy on
right the stuff and gravy has to be
Mando
M um stuffing and you got to put
stuffing SLG gravy it's combination
combination combination everything's
about the combination right um yes there
we go right number four we have to go uh
people I'm glad someone said fried
turkey people do not know about fried
turkey you got to have turkey with a
little bit of gravy but honestly you
could do turkey with a little bit of
gravy but I'm the type of guy I like
turkey with uh the yam sauce the yam
juice you take the turkey turkey with
the yam juice right um your sweet potato
juice so say turkey sweet potato juice
turkey with the sweet potato juice food
always got a touch right um so so that
that'll be number four right um number
three for me would definitely be about
uh oh I would say the cream corn the
cream corn uh yam juice with the turkey
yam juice turkey the cream corn when you
have a delicious cream corn oh man oh
man oh cream corn all right um number
two um collard greens and hot sauce if
you don't got collar greens in your
plate like true ghetto out the South
Uptown Vibe collar greens with red hot
oh I I can't even come to your
Thanksgiving I can't come I can't come
you're not like like come on you gotta
have the C greens with the red hot
collard greens with the red hot right um
and then uh and then number one when I
tell you this is this is what gets the H
you feel me um you got to get the mac
and cheese with the Gams and you got to
put it together for the combination the
combination the mac and cheese and yams
go together if your Mac and yams aren't
together I question you if you don't got
yams and Mac together you're just not
normal um you're just not normal you
can't be at my Thanksgiving I'm not
coming to your Thanksgiving um but this
is this is what a real plate looks like
this is a real plate my plate be about
I'm G to be two GNA be like 260 next
week after this game I'm glad we we we
get a week off because this is about to
be crazy right um that is the top five
for me without a doubt without a doubt
that is my top five argue with your mama
that's the top five period mac and
cheese and yams together period they got
it touch they got it touch they just go
well um too well together um
I would say you know my favorite thing
about Thanksgiving truly is when all my
family comes in it's really the game
nights like the games that me and my
family play it honestly if your
Thanksgiving don't got tunk um
Spades uh you know maybe
charades uh some scatories something
like that and it your your Thanksgiving
really a hit y'all really ain't that
close my my Thanksgiving got all of that
and it's just all family laughing joking
and things like that that's the best
part of Thanksgiving uh catching up with
your family and obviously the throwback
Stories the throwback stories of your
uncles your moms and them it is too
great um it's something that I can't I
can't it's something that's just it's
it's Untouchable to me
um and a typical uh Thanksgiving my mom
actually works up at 5:30 a.m. on
Thanksgiving to start cooking um she she
does everything she prepares everything
the night before the day of things given
goes to the game leaves early to make
sure I got a nice fresh plate for us to
eat after the game when everyone leaves
the game I got like 20 people in town
this week for Thanksgiving can't wait to
be with all of them um because they're
all so special to me and you know I
can't wait it's gonna be a fun weekend
it's gonna be a fun game you know when I
got certain people in town my son will
be in town so that might give you a clue
how well this game might go you know the
little lions back in ch let's take some
final questions from the chat um um
before we end the show let's take some
final questions from the
chat it's rumored that Kelsey's fam will
meet the Swift family tonight on Monday
Night Football do you think the Chiefs
will pull off the
win uh for my playoff seting hopes I
hope the Chiefs will pull off the win um
but the Eagles might have some Vengeance
to their mind uh that Super Bowl got him
a little hot I'm G tune into the game
after this it's gonna be a good one I'm
super excited to watch um but I hope the
Chiefs can win but the Eagles some mad
Eagle people might be out there that's
uh some eag they they looking and Kelsey
there was a tweet uh that uh Jason
Kelsey was pretty mad he's 0 and4
against the the Chiefs and he's looking
to turn that around so that lets you
know how they're look how much they
looking forward to this um so it's GNA
be a good match um I really can't wait
to watch it uh who are you picking OSU
or Michigan I'm going with Michigan um I
can never root for OSU um obviously that
Ohio State Penn State rivalry is just
too much we're always going OSU what are
yams wait did someone really ask that no
we're not even going to we're not even
going to get into that if you don't know
what yams are um I don't even know if
you could watch the podcast no more like
for real like that's that is a that is a
violation of Thanksgiving a violation
and I and you know what is your favorite
Thanksgiving dessert I heard Dan I don't
even know how to say his last name right
he said throw away sweet potato pie
sweet potato pie is not at your
Thanksgiving and if you do not have some
vanilla ice cream or some whipped cream
on your on your Thanksgiving meal table
do not invite me don't even ask me to be
your friend don't even ask me to come
over that is just a disgrace you do not
throw sweet potato pie away Dan you do
not do it you do not do it that is a
disgrace and
period um how far how far the Texans
going in the playoffs I think the Texans
has a chance to go pretty far I think uh
they could depending how good they keep
playing and how they keep jelling and
how things uh keep putting together uh I
think the Texans have a chance to go at
least at least past Wild Card divisional
if not AFC Championship game uh how many
secks are you going to have on
Thanksgiving uh I don't want to give
nobody no hopes or uh motivation but I
keep telling myself and I keep telling
my family and friends I want that turkey
leg I want that turkey leg I want to be
biting the turkey leg on Thanksgiving
I'm wishing everyone a Happy
Thanksgiving so I hope I have a pretty
dominant game um I'm speaking into
existence um they said Michael we need
you live don't use that C4 garbage again
uh we're not here to bash C4 C4 um for
the most part I done work with C4 before
they're a good brand um I just don't
think my body was used to what I took
and what I was taking uh and it it's
extremely caught me off guard I might
think I might take like a half a scoop
or below half a scoop of C4 uh before
game if I decide to take it again um oh
I did forget about the cornbread I am so
sorry y'all I can't believe I forgot the
cornbread I definitely forgot about the
cornbread uh shame on me I need to be
better cornbread and cream corn is in
the top five cornbread and cream corn uh
for sure um they're going to go together
now cornbread and cream corn um and
that's about it before we wrap we're
going to have a great game on
Thanksgiving D cowo Nation y'all know
what to do if you are coming to A T&T
Stadium let's turn it out if you're
spending Thanksgiving with your boy
Michael Parsons and the Dallas Cowboys
come out and show out it's going down
division rivalry Cowboys versus
Washington can't get better than this
Thursday Night Football get excited get
going because this is gonna be a good
one uh I can't wait to see you all there
we're gonna have a good one they got
these Elite receivers great running back
Sam how playing pretty good right now uh
great passing game it's going to go down
our defense has to come out and show out
at home and y'all know how we do it at
home so let's get ready let's go uh how
about them Cowboys I see you next week
on Monday on the edge super excited
let's get it love
[Music]
peace